I have a process you know hopefully
other people do too but my process one
of the things I do when I collaborate is
whatever the actor gives me I use I
don't go home and prepare a performance
and then come to the set and use that
performance that I prepared at home
whatever I work with at home I only I
only take it to a certain extent and
then when I go onstage I prepare myself
for the fact that the actor may give me
something completely different because
what has happened in the past and I see
it with other actors they'll tell
another actor how to act and the reason
why they do that is because they've
already planned what they want to do and
that other actor whatever they giving
them is interfering with that that's not
how it works you got to say yes to your
partner if they given you a line in a
certain way guess what you got to get up
off you're a double snakes and use that
that's my process of collaboration I
read it over and over and over again
just to find out it in actors terms the
given circumstances who you are what
people say about you all of that that's
the first thing I do and then I write a
bio of the character so that I get up I
try to fill it up as much as possible
what are her memories does she have
brothers and sisters how many what
secrets does she have what's a favorite
color I do all of that work first the
character is always ever-evolving just
like we evolve based on circumstances
that happen to us there could be things
that happen that we absolutely know how
it's going to affect you affect you but
you really don't know how it's going to
affect you and how it will make you veer
off course at any given time so whatever
prep work you do the next thing you have
to do
what actors and actors charms are you
leave yourself alone you leave yourself
absolutely alone and know that there
could be something that happens that
totally will be out of character
whatever the reaction will be in any
given scene also one thing that because
actives won't admit this also because
whatever you prepared could be wrong
there could be something that really
does surprise you and all of a sudden
you're woken up because another actor
gives you a line in a certain way and
you surprise yourself at your reaction
and you think wow that's interesting I
never thought of that when I was
preparing the character but it's
interesting it's those jewels that you
get when you just freefall with your
acting here's what I was given coral
rose I was given writing on the page but
absolutely dictated where I would go you
don't always get that when writing is
not good you have to fill in the blanks
and I always say the actors who should
get the awards are the actors who have
to make bad work good they're the ones
literally because that's when you have
to work overtime but Auguste told me
exactly where I needed to go as rose
that's it her journey is complete there
are no words that I could add a subtract
to it um but the difficulty of all that
is he wrote something that is so epic
and so complete in a journey that you
had to go there and then going there is
very uncomfortable it's very
uncomfortable to confront a husband who
literally is saying I'm leaving you I'm
having a baby with another woman and I'm
leaving you and I know you're not going
to have anything once I leave I very
uncomfortable
Sanford Meisner Stanislavski the Actors
Studio step Stella Adler they were huge
advocates of using life you know for
your work which you've got to be an
observer of life and a thief of life and
you have to loot use in to some extent
yourself but at the same time the reason
why I have a degree in theatre and I
went to Juilliard is the rest of it the
thing that takes you over the hurdle in
crafting operative word meaning crafting
a performance is that you can you can
leave it you can sort of have a little
shroud of protection around yourself and
have a semblance of control of your work
you know because you have to shape a
performance you just can't go you know
on the set and just go okay I'm going to
go hog-wild because the character is
going while he just punches a wall in
with is with this bare fist so I'm going
to do it and then walk away with broken
fingers
I don't want broken fingers I just want
to show you that it looks like I'm
breaking my fingers so it's some
technique craft is what allows me to
leave it behind and go home to my
husband and my child I always mentioned
to women mrs. Leigh Tyson biggest
influence absolutely hands-down um only
because her approach to her work always
is complete
excellence and she's 92 years old when
she comes on that set she treats
everything she does she digs into it
like it's like the best meal possible
and number two Meryl Streep I've seen
the way that woman conducts herself on
the set her research basically is so
extensive you have no idea some of the
questions she was asking during doubt I
was in shock you know like viola so what
is your character come from so okay so
who was your father did he have a union
job or a non-union job ah ba ba ba ba ba
it's amazing
and because I see the way she conducts
herself as a lady on the set she
understands the her responsibilities as
number one on the call sheet to create
an atmosphere that is comfortable enough
for everyone to create and um and I have
observed that and I've used it so those
two women absolutely
[Music]